[Música]
un tercer objeto Volador sin identificar
fue derribado en tres días sobre el
cielo de los grandes lagos frontera
entre Estados Unidos y Canadá el hecho
ocurre una semana después de que un
globo chino cruzara Estados Unidos
supuestamente realizando labores de
espionaje el pentágono dijo que aún no
puede confirmar si son chinos también
estos artefactos
las temperaturas en Argentina están
siendo las más altas de las últimas seis
décadas un fenómeno que mantendrá en
alerta al centro y noroeste del país en
los próximos días y que ha arruinado
gran parte de la cosecha de soja y maíz
por la falta de agua
el gobierno de Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva realizó un operativo policial que
consiguió desmontar gran parte de la
minería ilegal en la reserva indígena de
Llano mami consiguió así la primera
Victoria para la consecución de la
protección del medio ambiente una de sus
principales promesas electorales
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos el ejército estadounidense
derribó este domingo un nuevo objeto
Volador sin identificar se trata del
tercero desde el viernes el cuarto desde
el derribo del llamado globo chino el
sábado 4 de Febrero el objeto fue
derribado sobre el cielo de los grandes
lagos frontera entre Estados Unidos y
Canadá específicamente sobre el lago
Hurón luego de haberse cerrado
temporalmente el espacio aéreo sobre el
Lago Michigan el pentágono afirmó que no
denominan globos a estos objetos porque
aún desconocen su tecnología para
mantenerse en el aire y al ser
cuestionado de si se trataba de un
objeto extraterrestre dijo que aún no
podía descartarlo
tras el derribo del globo de la
República popular china el sábado pasado
hemos estado haciendo un escrutinio más
detallado de nuestro espacio aéreo y
incluye mejorar nuestro radar lo que
explica el aumento en la detección de
objetos en la última semana
también sabemos que muchas entidades
incluyendo países compañías
investigadores operan objetos para
investigaciones legítimas dicho esto
como no hemos podido de manera
definitiva determinar qué son estos
objetos hemos tomado la decisión de
derribarlos como medida de precaución
para proteger nuestra seguridad nacional
previamente hablamos desde Júpiter en
Florida con Luis fleischmann analista y
experto en seguridad y terrorismo quien
analizaba A qué podría deberse que se
estén interceptando más objetos que
anteriormente
yo solamente puedo especular al respecto
Rodrigo y te puedo decir que yo creo que
ahora más que antes y es por eso que
están siendo interceptados y la razón
puede llegar a tener que ver con
que hace poco hace pocos días se se
firmaron acuerdos donde se reforzó se
reforzaron las bases militares y las
relaciones militares con la filipinas
para ayudar a formar como un cinturón de
defensa En caso de que china invada
Taiwán eso es muy importante y por otro
lado sabemos que eso es una prioridad
para el presidente biden y esto preocupa
china quiere saber que Cuáles son los
planes de Estados Unidos con respecto a
Taiwán ellos quieren saber cuán
preparado está Estados Unidos y qué es
lo que van a hacer y qué es lo que no
van a hacer pero de nuevo yo esto es un
análisis
Argentina continúa viviendo las
temperaturas estivales más altas de las
últimas seis décadas el servicio
meteorológico nacional advirtió a los
ciudadanos del centro y noreste del país
para los próximos días mientras también
suceden sequías que arruinaron gran
parte de la cosecha de soja y maíz de la
temporada algo que tendrá consecuencias
sobre la inestable economía nacional
Ramiro cuevar berena nos cuenta más
Argentina está padeciendo la peor ola de
calor en seis décadas así lo ha
expresado el servicio meteorológico
nacional el cual emitió alertas por
temperaturas extremas en nueve
provincias del centro y el norte del
territorio y le pidió a los ciudadanos
que tengan cuidados especiales curando
estar siempre en lugar con sombra con
aire así que cuidándome pero hago
gimnasia bajo un árbol
cuando camino Procuro llevar gorros
sombrero hay que cuidarse Esta es la
octava ola de calor que afecta a la
nación Sudamericana acostumbrada a
recibir entre 4 y 5 en esta etapa del
año las temperaturas sofocantes también
llegaron a la Patagonia Argentina que
alcanzó los 42 grados en la costa de Río
negro durante la última semana sí
tenemos varios amigos que están acá y
dice que la temperatura de calor en
verano era muy fuerte se quejaban mucho
y
era sofocante y no no no no entendíamos
hasta que estamos viviendo ahora la
realidad
me gusta el calor pero estos calores son
demasiado fuertes ya yo soy partidaria
del calor porque en invierno su alergia
y estoy todo el invierno estornudando
estoy mal y me gusta el calor pero este
calor me ha llegado a decir que calor
tengo el servicio meteorológico aseguró
que los meses de noviembre a enero
fueron los más cálidos desde 1961
también generaron sequías en los campos
arruinando alrededor de la mitad de la
producción de soja y maíz de la
temporada algo que repercutirá en la
golpeada de economía nacional
el expresidente brasileño Yair bolsonara
informó que regresará a Brasil en las
próximas semanas en una iglesia
evangélica en donde se reunió con sus
seguidores el ex mandatario aseguró que
su misión sobre la Tierra aún no ha
terminado y merece la pena el riesgo de
Volver al país del que salió tras haber
perdido las elecciones frente a la
izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
bolsonaro está investigado por la
fiscalía brasileña por la intentona
golpista de miles de sus seguidores el 8
de enero a las sedes de los tres poderes
del estado en Brasilia
y también en Brasil el gobierno de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva consiguió su
primera Victoria contra la minería
ilegal en un operativo conjunto la
policía consiguió desmovilizar gran
parte de la minería ilegal en la reserva
indígena de Llano mami una acción
fundamental para la protección del medio
ambiente Alba Santana no se explica
les declararon la guerra y de momento
han ganado la primera batalla el
gobierno y la policía brasileña
desmantelaron gran parte de la minería
ilegal en una zona indígena del país
como en una película de acción los
organismos gubernamentales entre ellos
la funay encargada de la protección y
preservación de tierras indígenas
acorralaron a los mineros quemaron sus
barcos con combustible sus avionetas y
también sus excavadoras en un operativo
llevado a cabo en la tierra indígena
llanomami la mayor reserva indígena del
país protegida por ley y que ha sido
víctima de la minería ilegal en los
últimos años y es que los cerca de
20.000 Mineros registrados en la zona
desde 2019 han puesto contra las cuerdas
a los cerca de 30.000 indígenas de la
reserva el proceso ilegal ha traído
enfermedades abusos sexuales y violencia
Armada a las comunidades todo para
conseguir un bien muy Preciado el oro
por eso ante esta crisis humanitaria el
gobierno de Lula hizo una promesa sacar
de la zona a todos aquellos que no sean
indígenas
no sé cómo lo haremos pero les puedo
asegurar que la minería ilegal Se va a
terminar
en Brasil solo en 2022 la minería ilegal
creció en un
54%. una situación fruto del abandono
del estado y de la inaccesibilidad de
estas tierras no obstante Lula prometió
acabar con esta situación en todas las
zonas de la amazonía afectadas una tarea
tan necesaria como difícil en la que uno
de los mayores retos del gobierno será
rastrear a quienes financian Estas
actividades Más allá de los trabajadores
de Las Minas en su mayoría pobres y
sometidos incluso a la esclavitud solo
ponen presión sobre la gente pobre que
son mineros y ahora pienso no tengo
estudios y estoy jubilado sabes qué voy
a hacer para sobrevivir la minería
ilegal es el principal motivo de la
deforestación en la amazonía por eso el
plan de gobierno pretende proteger el
mayor bosque húmedo del mundo pero
también todas las etnias indígenas que
lo habitan y que son patrimonio de la
humanidad
jóvenes venezolanos chavistas y anti
chavistas marcharon este domingo por las
calles de Caracas para conmemorar el día
de la juventud del lado chavista fueron
miles quienes llegaron al palacio de
Miraflores en donde se encontraron con
el presidente Nicolás maduros los anti
chavistas juntaron en torno a medio
millar de personas para realizar
exigencias electorales ante el Consejo
Nacional electoral sin embargo un
contingente policial les impidió llegar
hasta el organismo
[Aplausos]
en la ciudad del Salvador en Brasil tuvo
lugar este domingo el baño de mar a
fantasía un evento carnavalesco
celebrado desde hace más de 70 años
algunos de los participantes se
congratularon del regreso de esta fiesta
luego de dos años sin celebrarse por la
pandemia de Kobe 19
con estas imágenes Nos despedimos sigan
conectados a France 24 y Recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web.com
[Música]